it took 24 days to find her and it was
the news nobody wanted to hear Nicola
bully the mum of two whose face has been
painted Across the Nation for the last
three weeks was indeed the body police
recovered from the river wire we are now
now able to confirm that yesterday we
recovered Nicola Bully from the river
wire
Nicholas family have been informed and
are of course devastated today's
development is not the outcome any of us
would have wanted
and a family heartbroken said this we
will never be able to comprehend what
Nikki had gone through in her last
moments and that will never leave us we
will never forget Nikki how could we
she was the center of our world
she was the one who made our lives so
special and nothing will cast a shadow
over that and then criticism of the
media and the way it has reported on the
investigation it Saturn's girls
members of the public
accuse their dad of wrongdoing
misquoted and vilified friends and
family
this is absolutely appalling
they have to be held accountable this
cannot happen to another family
we tried last night to take in what we
have been told in the day
only to have
Sky News
and ITV making contact with us directly
when we expressly asked for privacy
they again have taken it upon themselves
to run stories
about us to sell papers and increase
their own profits it is shameful
they have acted in this way
leave us alone now
their pain wasn't helped by three long
weeks of extensive searches including
divers boat scouring the Riverbanks and
high-tech sonar equipment there was no
sign of the 45 year old they all failed
to locate her in the end it was two dog
walkers that found Nicola it was along
this stretch of River where police
retrieved Nicola's body a mile
Downstream from where her phone her dog
Willow and its lead were discovered but
finding her isn't the end of this
investigation police are trying to piece
together how and why she ended up here
a 10-minute window of Nicholas movements
around this bench remains unaccounted
for it could be a mystery that may never
be resolved
but Lancashire police will need to
provide answers to the very top of
government I did have concerns earlier
in the week about some of the elements
really relating to the release of
personal information of Nicola bully
into the public domain I raise those
concerns with the chief Constable I
wasn't wholly satisfied I have to say
with some of the responses I got
in the village of Saint Michael's the
last three weeks will have felt like
time has stood still a small quaint
Community now dealing with great loss
and pain into man Rashid Sky News
Lancashire